so AFC playoffs let's do NFC AFC pick a
fancy hey do the wild card games three
is Houston against Jacksonville at six
Houston gets the win Pittsburgh has to
go to the Chargers no home-field
advantage Steelers move on that means in
the second round of visional round
it's Steelers at Patriots and it's
Texans at Ravens well guess what
Steelers upset the Patriots in
Foxborough ready to go but that's not
where the upsets stop Houston goes into
Baltimore and upsets the Ravens to Shaun
Watson moves on setting up an AFC
Championship game of the Houston Texans
and the Pittsburgh Steelers it's in
Houston what an amazing game that would
be first of all Houston's going to the
Super Bowl all right he was going there
the way he was staying Houston the take
me to the NFC left go NFC first wild
card matchup the Saints traveled to the
Cowboys and the Packers go to the Rams
Saints upset the Cowboys in the first
round of the playoffs and the Packers
upset the Rams I have a lot of upsets
Saints travel to Minnesota for a rematch
of the Minnesota miracle and they get
their revenge the Saints from the six
seed rumble themselves to the NFC
Championship game and Atlanta going ooh
we can face our in division rivals upset
by Aaron Rodgers Aaron Rodgers against
Drew Brees in the NFC Championship game
Aaron Rodgers goes to the Super Bowl
it's Aaron Rodgers versus Tom Watson
Green Bay versus Houston amazing super
amazing all right Sims bring me to the
AFC all right here we go all right my
number one seeds the Steelers the number
two seeds the Pats so they have the
first round bye I'm gonna go to the wild
card first my number three seeds the
Chargers they will be hosting the number
six seed Houston Texans I have the
Chargers moving on to win that football
okay so we're
on the Super Bowl or not number four
seed I have the Jacksonville Jaguars I
think they will be hosting the Baltimore
Ravens and their wild card game I'm
picking the Baltimore Ravens eye they
can handle the physicality of the
Jaguars they move on so now we have the
two seed Pat's hosting the three seed
chargers okay and then we have the 1
seed Steelers hosting the Ravens Wow
yeah pretty pretty cool either way I'll
be this will be really fun to watch I'm
going to pick the Chargers to be upset
the Pats as well we both have the
Patriots it's really four years they've
gone to the Super Bowl I mean even they
have to fall up at some point and their
divisional rounds are kind of the other
than last year with the Titans they you
know the Texans underwhelming right and
I just I look at the you know the rest
of the AFC's got to be going gosh damn
we're sick of the Patriots like if
they're not then they all need to like
get a reality check or something because
I mean damn it's good reality it's
unbelievable alright we're sick of you
whooping our ass okay you know what you
need a reality check you do quantify
that charge don't use my words charge
your brain not your heart yes right
that's why I did it here I don't know
actually I used my heart I think on that
one so Chargers beat the Pats during the
AFC championship games
Ravens one seed five seed I'm going with
the Steelers yes I'm going with the
Steelers and we got Steelers charge
Phillip Rivers and company coming to
town and Pittsburgh and late January I
just think it'll be a little too cold
the Steelers are gonna win
okay Steelers are the Superbowl I'm
going with it oh yeah the NFC NFC I have
the Saints is my one seed and the
Vikings is my two-seat first that's the
first round bye all right I got the Rams
as my three seed they are hosting the
number six seed Atlanta Falcons and I
saw this last year natural last year and
it'll be the same results the Falcons
will go into LA and you guys have the
Rams going down wildcard weekend yeah I
mean when I just look at the NSC I think
the worst quarterback in the playoffs is
still Jared Goff and he was definitely
the worst quarterback in the playoffs
total last year just by his performance
against the balcony I'm sure he'll be
really happy to hear that one
sure he'll want to meet us again next
year a training camp right stare you
down yeah okay and then I got the number
four seed Dallas Cowboys hosting Oh
Aaron Rodgers you always come into
Dallas and do amazing things and screw
our season or playoffs not so fast my
guess I plagiarized that from Lee Corso
but I don't care uh Cowboys gonna move
on they're gonna get the revenge on the
Green Bay Packers and Aaron Rodgers so
now I got the number one seed Saints
hosting the Falcons I'm going with the
Saints to beat the Falcons there a week
to prepare Sean Payton and company I
just think they'll be too much for the
Falcons and then we got the Cowboys
going to Minnesota a uber Peninsula
I'm going with the Cowboys Wow watch out
for the Vikings the Cowboys I just look
at it like this just a quick description
the Vikings their receivers or their
offense I don't know if it's explosive
enough to actually expose Dallas on
defense and what scares me always about
the Vikings even though their depth is a
little bit better they're gonna get worn
down by that Dallas Cowboy run gayness I
think the Cowboys pull the upset off
their now we got Saints Cowboys yeah in
the NFC Championship game Sean Payton oh
when the saints go marching in they're
gonna play the Steelers in the Superbowl
Thursday picture with all the animals
stains Saints Steelers Superbowl I can't
say it but I can I can't wait to see it
played all right so in this corner we
have the Texans facing the Green Bay
Packers in the Super Bowl let go in this
corner Chris Sims we have the Pittsburgh
Steelers taking on the New Orleans
Saints Adam left go take us through how
the Super Bowl unfolds Wow well I don't
know who I'm picking yet I'm going to do
this on the fly right now you're gonna
talk it out yeah that'll be the grand
finale
I believe that early on the Houston
defensive line is pushing Green Bay
that's the story of Houston it's not
just a Shawn Watson it's what that
defense is gonna do to people and then
DeShawn's gonna make some moves
but old number 12 old number 12 rolls
right finds Jimmy Graham in the back of
the endzone then he's got one where DJ
reader is dropped and he slips and
Rodgers does his patented little scoot
hop away from the sack jump so his legs
cross a minute here scoot huh and who is
that in the back of the endzone none
other than Davante Adams Aaron Rodgers
wins his second Super Bowl the Green Bay
Packers are your Super Bowl champions
well done Chris James I would certainly
be happy to see that what are the
likelihood that it's gonna happen though
all right Pittsburgh Steelers New
Orleans Saints Pittsburgh Steelers New
Orleans Saints in a stadium that the
Saints are familiar with because the
Superbowl is in Atlanta this year it's
correct don't it's indoors with the
Saints man this is a really tough I
think it's very evenly matched across
the board I think what really will make
the difference for me is I just think
the Steelers have a few too many
playmakers for me to take the Saints
over them I think this will be an
awesome Super Bowl if you made me break
it down I don't know if the Saints have
enough difference-makers to slow down
Pittsburgh on the first the offensive
side of the ball
Pittsburgh's old line is really good we
know the receivers are the good let me
on bill should be levy on bail by that
time of the year we hope and yeah I just
look at that matchup but I'm super up on
the Steelers right now when I think of
the Saints hey the Saints are gonna move
the ball in that Pittsburgh defense -
but I think Pittsburgh's got ballers
that can change the flow of that
football game at some point whether it's
an Antonio Brown on offense making an
amazing play or a bud Dupree or Stefon
to it coming in or even my man Terrell
Edmonds making that kind of play and I'm
gonna go with the Pittsburgh Steelers to
win the Super Bowl
and there it is